and if you want uh if you want an honest
answer the other trick uh is to is is to
uh not use psychedelics but you should
you should try smoking so smoking is is
smoking and cups of tea oh
or i actually smoke a pipe but the
cigarettes will do in an emergency so
there are certain neurotron
manipulations of neurotransmitters the
first time a doctor has recommended
smokey
yes
well i hope we have a select audience
for this
well so yeah
continue could you finish up your
thought i'm sorry
you're saying the smoking of the pipe
does what because i'm not the type of i
don't smoke and nor do i want to smoke
but you're saying that the smoking does
what was the purpose of the smoking
it's just a way of using um nuancing
your neurotransmitters that control that
synaptic gain or the gain and the weight
you afford different
different parts of your um belief
updating
so it has the opposite effect of
psychedelics basically so
that's why people like tea and you know
have a cup of tea come that you know
stay calm and
carry on wherever it is nice cup of tea
cigarette and cup of coffee that yeah
that'll sort you out and it's because
all of these um drugs the caffeine the
nicotine they all act on the same
kind of um receptors um
at different levels in your neuronal
hierarchy um that are responsible for
setting that gain control and gaiting
doing the attention and the the
attenuation aspects that we're talking
about so it's just a way of getting
physical control over your hierarchical
belief updating
a bit like you're about
i would have thought that the caffeine
would have the opposite effect of
increasing your anxiety
not not necessarily no um yeah
you know if well it clearly depends um
if you're very agitated um um
then um
that could certainly be the case but if
you're if
if you are
worried that you might be anxious and in
fact you're not then desensitizing
certain um
certain interceptive sensations um
that register that in fact you're not
telling me your heart isn't pounding
that'll actually calm you down a little
bit
uh if it goes too far then beta blockers
will be an another nice example of
that's what i used actually
all right oh well there you are so what
i'm trying to say is sometimes
with skillful use the use of a tobacco
pipe can have the same kind of effects
as a vitablogger